Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số 4
nhóm các hàm đếm Thì trước khi bắt đầu
vào học số 4 mình sẽ giải các bài tập
của cái bài số 3 hôm trước nhá đây các
bạn sẽ thích bảo cái bài Bà đây các bạn
sẽ thích và câu hỏi các bạn chú ý nhất
link tải pha thực hành của mỗi bài mình
đã để ở dưới video thì tốt nhất là các
bạn tải về các bạn vừa theo dõi và thực
hành cùng mình nếu như bạn nào không
biết cách tải về thì các bạn sẽ xem cái
bài đầu tiên là cái bài giới thiệu về
excel của khóa học này nhá lại các bạn
rất thích đụng vào cái file câu hỏi là
đấy câu hỏi của mình là gì mình sẽ dùng
cái làm xong mấy mét để mình tính tổng
doanh thu theo sản phẩm và theo cái khu
vực ở trên này đúng ạ ơi các bạn sẽ tích
vào cái ô G6 để mình làm công thức các
bạn bằng xong ít e đúng ạ Các bạn Hiến
pháp đầu tiên là xong lên là cái vùng
tính tổng của các bạn sẽ vẫn là Model
với doanh thu này Đấy gọn sẽ nhấn F4 để
cố định toàn bộ các phần tham chiếu nhất
thì các bạn phải cố định cho mình là các
bạn sẽ nhấn F4
Ừ vậy Tiếp theo là cái vùng điều kiện
thứ nhất là theo sản phẩm nên chọn bộ
derby vùng sản phẩm vào đây các bạn nhấn
F4 để cố định phải theo điều kiện sản
phẩm ở đây đúng không phải cái vùng điều
kiện thứ 2 là diện theo khu vực bạn
Model khu vực gần đây các bạn F4 để cố
định phải theo cái khu vực ở đây thì cái
OVA 4 này các bạn cần phải cố định tại
vì cái công thức này mình sẽ áp dụng cho
các khách hàng dưới này để cho nên cái ô
G41 đấy phải cố định các bạn sẽ nhấn F4
đấy các bạn xem nó ngoác lại các bạn
enter lại thì nó sẽ ra tầm thường này
còn tích tụ ở đâu đấy Mình cho vào cái
hôm các bạn sẽ thích vào đây nè Mình
đang khách hàng nghìn cho nó dễ
Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ nổi bác Thành điện Ví
dụ mình đổi thành miền Trung các enter
Gái Gọi thế cho cái kết quả nó sẽ tự
động thay đổi theo đây ví dụ là miền Nam
đấy các bạn theo rất là hay
a tiếp theo là gì mình rất làm cái ví dụ
thứ ba là tính tổng có ba điều kiện nhé
thì nó cũng tương tự như vậy thôi các
bạn sẽ bằng các bạn sẽ bằng Sam FS các
bạn đánh tát nhé đầu tiên xong lên vẫn
là cái vùng doanh thu này các bạn F4 này
cố định phải cái vùng điều kiện thứ nhất
là theo khu vực đó các bạn sẽ Bôi đen
khu vực S4 phẩm theo cái khu vực ở đây
là F16 đúng không còn phải vùng điều
kiện thứ hai là điện là sản phẩm vào đây
các bạn F4 để cố định phải theo cái sản
phẩm về trên này các bạn sẽ nhấn F4 của
các sản phẩm Ova 14 này nhá phải tiếp
theo là cái điều kiện thứ ba đúng không
cái điều kiện thứ 3 là địa chỉ những cái
doanh thu mà lớn hơn 800.000 rồi đúng
không Thì cái điều kiện vẫn lại chính là
cái phần doanh thu ở đây tại vì mình chỉ
tính tổng cái doanh thu và lớn 8.000
đúng không để cậu sẽ nhấn F4 để cố định
cái vùng doanh thu này phải tiếp theo là
lớn hơn 800.000 nhóm nào lấy gọi cho mở
ngoặc kép là gọi sẽ ghi là điện lớn hơn
800.000 đấy một hai ba ngày qua sân đóng
ngoặc ở các đơn này hãy gọi M2 còn thấy
chứ không thì đưa vào đây
Đấy thì nó sẽ ra nha Bây giờ mình sẽ
kiểm tra các bạn xem nhé
bây giờ ví dụ mình sẽ boleyn sản phẩm
cũng hay đi đấy sản phẩm không ai sao
lại bằng không hết thế này
I sản phẩm không ai Tại vì không có cái
doanh thu nào lớn hơn 800.000 đ ví dụ về
tích vào đây sản phẩm + body đã sản phẩm
ba thì OK nhé Để như vậy mình đã làm
xong với hiện tính làm sao ghép với ba
điều kiện rồi nhé
Ok hôm nay mình sẽ làm bài số 4 nhé là
nhóm các cái hàm đếm các bạn sẽ thích
đút vào đây là cái file thực hành nhé á
ở đây thì đầu tiên là gì ạ Đây Giả sử
đây là cái vùng dữ liệu của mình ở đây
mình đã Liệt kê các cái cú pháp của các
hàm đến rồi nhá đầu tiên là cái hàm cao
cái hàm cao là điện đến các ô chữ số
thôi tức là cái ô mà chữ số thì nhắc ví
dụ cái ô mà các Baron đấy Mà không chứa
xấu thì nó sẽ không đến còn cái cao
blang là đến các cái ô rỗng Tức là ví dụ
mình Bôi đen hay ô này lâu giống đúng
không nữa cao lanh nó sẽ bằng 2a
khi còn bé cao AH là gì nó sẽ đến tất cả
các ô chứa ký tự từ nhà chứa cả số cả
chữ cái cả dấu cách cái gì đấy nó đều
tính nhá Còn cái hàm cao ít là đếm mà có
điều kiện mà đến có một điều kiện đây
nhá lại còn tương tự cái hàm cao ghét
thì nó đến sẽ nghĩ nhiều điều kiện thì
cái hàng Café tôi thì nó lại giống hệt
cú pháp của cam ít nhưng mà nó sẽ lặp
lại các cái vùng điều kiện và điều kiện
này
Ok mình sẽ thực hành nhá đầu tiên là
riêng mình sẽ dùng cái hàm cao ở đây là
cái vùng dữ liệu của mình nhá thịt câu
hỏi số 1 là riêng mình sẽ đến các cô mà
chứa giá trị số đúng không ở đây là các
bạn chú nhắc cái giá trị số Tức là mình
phải dùng để làm cao bình thường rồi
đúng không để đoạn tích bằng cái ô K1 để
các bạn làm không rất lại bằng các bạn
gõ chữ cam đấy bọn chúng á nếu như cái
chữ cao đầu tiên ở đây rồi con có thể ấm
áp luôn để tao không cần phải gõ đầy đủ
luôn lại thì bạn sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái
vùng dữ liệu đây là gì ạ từ 32 đến S8
này đấy Gọi sự đóng ngoặc bạn Ừ thì như
vậy Ở đây tất cả là có 24 Ô mà chứa giá
trị số này tức là ví dụ các CD là không
tính được nhá bê này là tách trứng ngoài
là xấu là chuỗi trong màn số Ampe này là
chuỗi không mà xấu nhá đây ví dụ 14 28
thì được D hoặc ô trống thì không tính
nhá
Câu thứ hai đếm các ô mà có cả số và chữ
thì tức là mình phải dùng cái hàm cao
dồi cho nó ra đếm hết đúng không ạ bằng
cao a gọi ấn mỗi cái xuống này cái cao
gót tô đậm rồi đúng không các bạn sẽ
giúp tác thì cái hòm cao AH đây này họ
sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu nữa
còn sẽ đóng bác là enter thì như vậy là
cái vùng dữ liệu của mình ở đây là gì 32
Ô mà có chứa ký tự còn chú ngựa đây là
mình có tất cả là mấy mấy hàng ở đây có
tất cả các cao là nó bậy hàng đúng không
Mình xem bao nhiêu phút Đây là năm cụt
như vậy là 75 35 tất cả mình sẽ có 35 ôm
đúng không Để như vậy Ở đây là đến cái ô
mà có ký tự số và chữ là 32 đúng không
như vậy là có bao không chứ số
104 anh này hay Black 3 Black đây 32 ô
này là một like đấy còn gì nhỉ Đúng rồi
nhá
a tiếp theo là đến các cô và rỗng Thế là
không có gì đâu anh thì mình dùng cao
còn anh không gọi cao là để cậu sẽ nhấn
mũi tên xuống nhấn mũi tên xuống khi nào
mà cái cam lang này nó được tô đậm thì
các bạn tác đấy các bạn cũng bôi đen
toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu Thôi để đã xem
enter nó sẽ bằng ba bây giờ xử với ông
này đang giống như mình sẽ gõ ra Excel
này
lại cảm thấy chứ Cái này nó sẽ giảm thứ
hai và cái này tăng lên 1 tháng 3 3 và
cái này không tăng Với cả tại vì cái gái
sau đó là nó là chuỗi chứ không phải là
số mày Ví dụ mình sẽ thay gái xe bằng 1
các bạn m lại cái này nó sẽ tăng lên
thành 2 năm bây giờ Mày xóa đi Đấy thì
nó lại trở về ban đầu là 33224 nhé
tiếp theo là gì mình sẽ đến các ô mà bắt
đầu bằng chữ con lại bắt đầu chỉ con
nhắc ví dụ này diện không ăn này
ta đi không phải xong không phải campell
vào computer tức là có bao bắt đầu trẻ
con đúng không lại thì các bạn phải dùng
hàm cao ít ở đây nó chỉ đến một điều
kiện thôi Vậy thì thôi mình cứ dùng hàng
K bít trước nhé bằng cao ít này à
anh phải gọi điện áp chỉ đầu tiên là dán
cái vùng điều kiện toàn bộ cái vùng dữ
liệu này đúng không để bạn phải điều
kiện là gì Các bạn mở khóa két ra là chỉ
con chọn đóng ngoặc kép lại các bạn đó
ngoặc đơn ạ Nếu như các bạn dùng cái làm
này thì nó sẽ trả được không Tại vì sao
ạ Tại vì nó sẽ so sánh với chữ con không
tôi không mang đến nó khác với con mà
không về khác với con với cậu enter Xem
đấy Đã xem ảnh không Bây giờ con có kích
nút đây vào đây được sửa nhé Vậy làm thế
nào để nó hiểu là bắt đầu chứ con ấy thì
gọi rất đơn giản với gọi thêm các ký tự
sau và sau với chứ Con này tức là mình
chỉ quan tâm 3 thì ký tự đầu là con thôi
còn sau này nó sẽ đại diện cho bất kỳ
cái chuỗi ký tự nào sau nó mình sẽ không
quan tâm sau đó là gì cả thấy gọi enter
đấy nó sẽ trả về ba đúng ạ Đấy đấy ví dụ
các bạn nếu mà thêm một cái ký tự trước
con mới được các bạn sự thêm chữ t chiếc
compa đây ạ còn thấy nó sẽ gắn 12 rồi
Bây giờ làm thế nào Ví dụ mình muốn câu
hỏi của mình là điện đến các cô mà Chứ
chứ con thôi tức là mình sẽ không quan
tâm hai lần cuối lợn thì nó chỉ cần đơn
giản bạn thêm với sao ở trước con vậy
thôi tức là mình diện Mình chỉ quan tâm
với chuỗi đấy đâu có chứa con cá con
enter nó sẽ bằng 3 ngay Đấy đấy là cái
cách mà mình sử dụng cái sao nhé Và bây
giờ mình sẽ xóa đi mình sẽ trở về đúng
với yêu cầu của bài toán đi đây cái cắt
ra mình sẽ xóa chữ t đi nhá này Rồi
enter để nó sẽ bằng 3 tiếp theo là việc
mình sẽ đến các cô mà lớn hơn 50 và nhỏ
hơn 60 thì như vậy Ở đây là gì đây là
nhiều điều kiện rồi đúng không Điều kiện
thứ nhất là lớn hơn 50 và điều kiện thứ
hai là nhỏ 60 đợi thì cho nên mình phải
dùng hàm countif bằng k bit là các bạn
ấn mũi tên xuống này các bạn tác Ờ thì
đầu tiên là gì ạ Cái vùng điều kiện thứ
nhất Đúng là các nguyên nhân vẫn là toàn
bộ cái vùng dữ liệu này sẽ gặp phải gọn
Mở của kem ra gọn ghi là diện lớn hơn 50
cho nó khép lại phải tiếp theo là vùng
điều kiện thứ hai đúng không vẫn là cái
vùng này thấy cần phải Điều kiện thứ hai
là nhiệt độ mở của kem còn nhỏ hơn 60
tạo sẽ đóng ngoặc kép lại còn sẽ đóng
ngoặc đơn đấy cho enter thì như vậy là
diện có 5 ô và lớn hơn 50 và 60 đây mình
sẽ kiểm tra nhé đầu tiên là 57 cả giữ
gần chôn này năm sáu này 53 này
số 51 52 đã đoạn Thấy chưa nhẹ như vậy
là nam mô mà lớn hơn 50 và cho 60
ạ bây giờ quay lại cái ví dụ thứ 4 nhá
thì mình hoàn toàn có thể dùng các hàm
cao huyết áp thai hàng K bit có túc ở đó
các bạn chỉ cần thêm chữ s thôi tại vì
cái cú pháp của cao ít và cái vs đó là
giống nhau đó chỉ tăng thêm với số vùng
điều kiện và điều kiện cho các bạn xem
tôi cũng được đấy nó không khác gì nhau
cả cái cú pháp của nó là giống nhau khác
với cả xong rồi sau mới biết là như vậy
nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ xem cái bài tập về
nhà của cái phần các cái hành đến đây
nhá
này các bạn sẽ tích và wi-fi câu hỏi
ở lại câu hỏi là đại diện ở đây mình có
cái kết quả thi cuối khóa ở đây là yêu
cầu gì số thí sinh động tức là điểm
trung bình lớn bằng 6 đây các bạn phải
tính cái cột điện trung bình là bao
nhiêu thí sinh dưới 16 là số thi rớt này
trung bình lớn 8 lại họ sẽ làm với bài
tập này nhé
Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học
ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã
theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập
nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia
sẻ để giúp mọi người có học Excel nhé
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại à
[âm nhạc]